hey guys this is Pete peppers and this
is a candy crush soda saga level 375
commentary video with some tips and i
made this video earlier today for
something else and I thought I would
come back and explain the decisions I
made because 375 is a really tough level
so I'm going to pause it here and there
and just explain the strategy in each
room in a basic way and talk about some
of the decisions I made I did realize I
made a couple mistakes but they're still
lucky enough to finish so you know one
of the one thing to keep in mind right
from the beginning is to hang in there
and even though it's really tough and
this took me several tries to get you'll
eventually get it if you're thinking
about how to get through each one so the
common theme in all the rooms is to have
as many moves left over as you can so in
this first room we start with 45 I want
to get out of here with like 41 or 42
moves left over if I can and the fastest
way to do that is to work straight down
the middle because the but the bear at
the bottom here is actually you know got
the double layer on it where the other
ones are only single layers so no need
to get real fancy just try to bust
through as fast as we can and we're
going to start out here with the match
of the blue that'll knock the top bear
off right away we can match this orange
and just really quickly you might have
solved that we had a purple match on the
right that would have made it fit would
made fish that have been fine too
they're about even all right light I
know that that that wrapped candies head
in there so when we set that off it's
going to it's going to take both layers
off the middle bear so that's fine like
that to just work down the middle if you
can so we'll make this match with the
with the red wrapped candy and that will
clear out this room and we'll get out
with 42 moods so that's that's a good
start now one thing that drove me crazy
when i was playing this this
ticular level was that sometimes you get
a really good room and then you get to
the next one and you just be completely
stuck and you know say you get through
the first two rooms really fast and you
get to the third room and you're just
stuck in there that you can do and it
makes it worse but you know that as long
as you don't as long as you have around
20 moves or so left when you go into the
last room you're okay so I don't usually
see I don't usually quit use the quit
button unless I'm you know that far down
and in this room the you know if you're
just as well to like do what I'm doing
here and just sort of hit the bears
directly the little one in the middle is
the hardest one the one that I'm looking
at right now and a couple fish would
will get us to where we need to go so
that's what I'm thinking about as I go
and now I can make the purple fish at
the top that I'll take the first level
and then the blue one will take the
second and so we were stuck there a
little bit but we have roughly 12 moves
to get through the next room so we're
going to see if we can do that and the
biggest thing here is the coils the
coals get in the way and they really
block you from knocking out a lot of
bears at the same time so if there's
nothing better to to hit as far as like
you know taking bears out directly then
I go straight for the coils just to get
rid of them as fast as I can and if we
you know vertical stripes are good here
if you can match him with fish because
that'll hit that whole row and this is
one of the mistakes i was talking about
i thought i made was like you know it
worked out where i got a fish a purple
fish at the bottom but i think i should
have utilized that middle one instead
and then here this looks a little bit
confusing what I was doing but I was
trying to set up this um
color bottom right here with the light
blue like I do and then whenever I make
this match with the striped in the color
ball i'm not sure if it's going to get
all of them but it's going to get enough
of them and get a cascade going that i
feel like i'll probably get out of here
Oh 20 Mouse or 19 so second in third
room wasn't really that good but we
still have a chance and here we are so
I'm going to pause again because this
last room is definitely the worst and
one thing to keep in mind is that you do
have any specials you made in the first
room it which includes one wrapped candy
that was there and under the honey that
will be up at the top so you know I want
to get rid of the hunting as fast as I
can in the middle and i do want to take
out these coils as well just in case i
get fun you know striped candies or or
purple stripes that you know the dark
purple stripes that will hit these bears
that are hidden behind the honey in the
bottom so on the verse first moves
pretty simple i can match the red and
orange at the same time and that will
hit two of the honey squares and well
three because it'll actually hit that
one in the middle too so that's a good
match and you know the best thing i can
say about this room is is to take your
time you know it's just I've benden's
I've gotten here with 30 moves before
and didn't finish so it's just really
important to make every match account
that you can and so you know we want to
hit this we do have a caller bomb under
this honey in the middle so we want to
work on that one but just don't forget
about the ones at the top either because
you want to get rid of those and this is
a good striped but as you can see the
coils at the bottom blocked it from
hitting any of the Bears below so that
that's not the best but you know
sometimes that's the way it works out
and the reason I did that that's kind of
a strange looking move was to was to
actually get rid of the coils before I
said set out to open up
the collar bomb because what i want to
do now is you can see that the rap candy
fell from up above so i want to match
those two together if i can you tell
them make a combo to it you know with
the color bomb and the rat candy if i
can so we're kind of stuck a little bit
here with not a lot of great moves but
we luckily we get a shuffle so i can hit
the hit that there then i can match the
yellow i could also that's one of them
that's actually one of the mistakes i
was talking about i could have actually
made the fish on the right when i saw
the yellow and i knew that this was
going to set up my combo so it's not the
end of the world but it would have been
actually a better match to make the fish
first because it would have it would
have done the exact same thing except
for it would have sent for purple fish
after four of the six bears that we need
so luckily like i said i was able to
finish anyways but those are the kinds
of things that you really want to watch
out for and so what you know the the
striped plus the color balm is a great
match for this level for that reason you
see how it cleared out a lot of honey
for us and now we have one bear up top
one on the second level which shouldn't
be too hard and the three and the
bottoms are going to be the hardest ones
so my main strategy here i'm going to
make the color bomb with the right at
the top because that's you know pretty
much always good but what i want to do
is get that bear in the middle taken
care of so that I came numb I can have
some space so as a general rule I always
try to go down in the middle as fast as
i can in this room similar it's a lot of
the other levels we played with honey at
the bottom that I like that move that I
made there with the color bomb plus the
fish and then you know again obviously
that's a good match to do with the
the purple candy again and here's
another place where I kind of made a
mistake like I don't mind I don't mind
not making the color bomb shape with the
dark purples there because it doesn't
really do a lot it would get one layer
here but what I do instead is I miss out
on this fish over here this dark purple
fish on the right-hand side because it
looks like it's a sideways stripe and if
I just bring that down instead I only
have one hit left to go with nine moves
and that's a lot better but because
there was other stuff going on I just
really didn't pay that much attention as
much as I should have and I go ahead and
make the yellow fish at the bottom I
think so that I can match those two
together and that's not a that's not a
terrible move because it brings me the
striped and here that I can set off now
but I can pound the mistake by instead
of making that a fish I make it a stripe
if I make that a fish I'm almost done
like I said instead I made a stripe and
now I have six months six moves and I
have a pretty tough setup so what I'd
like to do is I just set off the striped
candy at the bottom but I can't get any
blue down there immediately so I have to
work around and try to set something up
so i think what i end up doing here
right here is that I am I match the fish
with the wrapped you know and that'll
get me one but now I have to set off
this striped candy in the next four
moves in order to finish so here I don't
mind the move I just decide I go red and
green on the side that kind of get rid
of this honey and that's blocking the
mayor and it actually takes up a big
spot and you know make some room but now
you can see I don't really have that
many good choices
so I could you know move it move over
this orange here and do that but I
decided instead that I'm going to try to
make a cascade because if I move up the
stripes at the bottom I'm definitely
going to get the right side bear but I
don't think I'm gonna get the left side
because of the honey that's blocking so
what I do is I try to drop things down
and the green strike that the top ends
up starting a chain reaction and I
finish it that way so um like I said not
a perfect last room but that should
hopefully give you some hope that if you
are you know moving pretty quickly make
the right decisions early that you can
still have a chance you know this like I
said it's a really tough level but you
can do it you can see I have this one
I'll also link to my original video
where I beat it without visitors as well
and i hope you liked the video with the
texts and i hope they help out and
please like the videos show some support
and subscribe to our channel so that
you'll know when we have new stuff
coming out we make new videos like this
you know when we can and if you have any
questions leave them in the comments and
if you're really struggling with
something just let us know and we'll try
to make a video as soon as we can
alright thanks